it's 1917 and America is embroiled in
a world of war and feeding doughboys
at point of embarkation are America's
angels of mercy women of the American
Red Cross since granted its charter
by act of Congress 5th of January
nineteen five Red Cross has waged
constant war against human suffering
in battle-torn France Red Cross ambulances are
familiar sites Red Cross Angelus drivers heroic
figures to the wounded and worried warriors of
democracy and Red Cross workers are never far
from the fighting front are ever on hand to aid
the battle weary soldier ah American cigarettes
almost as thrilling as letters from loved ones
at home at base hospitals in England Red Cross
nurses care for the inevitable casualties of
war here Red Cross women help heal the hearts
that must beat in broken bodies nurse the
wounded back to normal thinking normal life
they see deep suffering and must
deeply suffer - but still they
laugh and play as if their heart too
light for this is help for the wounded
at home as well as the base hospitals in the
fighting front Red Cross workers of
World War one ate our troops abroad
with time as well as needle and
thread they give whatever help
they can to those who are overseas
or like this sailor going over soon
and when our victorious troops returned Red
Cross nurses are first to welcome them back home
but heroics are not forgotten after pieces
one Brunswick New Jersey becomes site of
memorial to the heroism and sacrifice
of the Red Cross ambulance driver in
midst of war they too were courageous at
chateau-thierry news are gone and the mourn